what you thought I was going to get
through this month without being
controversial
[Music]
history is important yes those who fail
to remember the lessons of History are
doomed to repeat them blah blah blah
blah blah we know that one but history
is important for another big reason
those whose history is told shapes the
current world
one of the more deeply problematic ways
to view history and if you grow up in
the U.S it's probably the version of
history that you were taught is the
Great Men perspective focusing on
individuals who it is believed most
shaped the world we get taught names
like Henry VIII Galileo Martin Luther
King Jr Abraham Lincoln Julius Caesar
Queen Elizabeth the first Alexander the
Great Attila the Hun and more and are
told that these are the people who
shaped history often ignoring the
context they come from and the fact that
for every one great person great man
more often than not there are millions
of nameless people whose very real
contributions went unrecorded
a quick shorthand for the kind of person
who shaped history and is usually
forgotten is Frank Wills don't know who
Frank Wills Is Well he was the security
guard at the Watergate complex who
noticed that several doors were being
kept open with tape over the latches and
then proceeded to call the police
kicking off the investigation that would
eventually cause then president Richard
Nixon to resign from the office of
president in disgrace if Frank Wills
hadn't noticed the tape on a routine
security route at the complex that
entire chapter of History might have
gone very differently
so the Great Men view of history is
already deeply flawed on its own but you
know what's even more aggravating
when key aspects of those great men even
the ones who aren't men are left out of
the telling today we're going to talk
about people you've probably heard of
and likely even studied in school at
least briefly
but also probably weren't told that they
were in some way lgbtqia plus
queer history has a very long history of
Erasure and I could easily go into some
of the amazing queer people we should
learn about but just don't such as blues
icons Gladys Bentley and Bessie Smith or
Dr Alan Hart a trans man who graduated
at the top of his medical school in 1917
or Dr Margaret Chung the first
american-born Chinese woman to become a
doctor or Lucy Hicks Anderson a trans
woman who fought for marriage equality
back in the 1920s
huh
you know it's funny how many of those
are women of color
but while all of them and countless more
are amazing and you should totally read
up on them what I want to focus on today
is the straight washing of major
historical figures
why is this important
well to put it bluntly
it'd be a hell of a lot harder for
bigots and political opportunities to
claim that queer identities are made up
and somehow new and invading Modern Life
if as a culture we actually had a
working knowledge of queer people
throughout history
generally queer people are likely to
just be purged from the history books
altogether but when they are too notable
or left too big a mark to be able to
pretend that they didn't exist well
well then you just pretend they weren't
queer
you don't talk about it or you adamantly
claimed that they were straight same
Erasure half the calories
plus it's also kind of funny to see
status quo Warriors freak out when you
bring up some of these because that's
the other thing I'm admittedly not doing
deep Dives here and some of the people
I'm going to talk about have more solid
evidence of their queerness than others
and I will readily admit to that upfront
and I'll point it out as we go some of
these have stronger foundations than
others but you will see conservatives
and academics bend over backwards to
rationalize any possible non-queer
explanation for most if not all of the
things I'm about to talk about anything
to keep from acknowledging even the
possibility that these people aren't
straight
so yes
for many of the folks I'll be touching
on today saying that they weren't
straight is generally considered a
contested View
but even though I can't prove to you 100
absolutely that this was the case it
says a lot about how stigmatized being
queer is that anything short of that 100
Proof gets shouted down as being
speculative when saying that these
people were absolutely straight is just
as speculative and often it flies in the
face of evidence that certain folks
don't like you look up the Wikipedia
entries for these people virtually all
of them will have some note that claims
their sexuality is contested or
controversial because never should it be
that the academic world finds evidence
of queerness and just goes oh okay well
that's all right then
so now that I have primed some viewers
to get excited and others to get
preemptively angry
let's talk some queer history Leonardo
da Vinci maybe the single most famous
artist in all of recorded history
whether it be the Mona Lisa the last
supper or his famous sketches for
inventions that seem centuries ahead of
their time he's well recognized as a
genius in numerous fields
he also wasn't straight
there's the big red flag that he never
married nor had any children not even
illegitimate ones so far as the history
shows but that's only a partial
indicator I mean
maybe he just never met the right girl
or you know maybe he was having affairs
with some of his students like Francesco
de melzi when he wasn't drawing Saleh
another of his students nude with
evident uh
excitement
and even if you don't think that's
enough to go on in 1476 Da Vinci and
several others were charged with sodomy
and patronizing a known male prostitute
those charges were dropped officially
for lack of evidence but while it's
possible that this means he didn't do
what he was accused of
it actually seems more likely that the
charges were dropped because one of the
others who was also accused was a member
of the highly influential Medici family
no known relationships with women no
kids legal record of sodomy accusation
Andrew his students naked Leonardo da
Vinci not straight if you ever learned
about the Harlem Renaissance in school
most likely in English or American
history class then you should be well
familiar with the name Langston Hughes
or at the very least if you're a theater
kid you should recognize the name drop
from one of the songs in rent
poet playwright novelist and activist
Langston Hughes has become an icon of
the creative world and while he didn't
come out in his lifetime and he had no
confirmed lovers pretty much nobody
argues that he was straight though
they'll frequently opt to avoid the
topic if they can help it hold on to
that phrase because it's going to be a
running theme
Hughes appeared to be quite careful not
to link himself directly to the queer
community of his day in any of his
written works though he would sneak in
bits of support here and there
degenerates some folks say
but God nature or somebody made them
that way there's a clear agreement
amongst his various biographers that
Hughes preferred the company of black
men in pretty much all aspects of his
life though some will still deny his
homosexuality by claiming Hughes was
more likely of the asexual persuasion
which is a slightly odd claim given some
of his poetic works but that still
leaves things pretty clear be it gay or
Ace Langston Hughes not straight when
you think of astronauts you probably
conjure an image of square jawed
All-American manly men with military
haircuts and Never Say Die attitudes and
fair enough that's kind of what NASA
wanted you to think of for a long time
but in 1983 Sally Ride became the Third
Woman and first American woman to travel
in space
and ride was a lesbian
now In fairness she never came out
publicly during her lifetime ride was a
very private person she kept her 27 year
long partnership with Tam O'Shaughnessy
along with her own declining health and
later her life to herself and out of the
public eye
but since her passing multiple people
close to her have confirmed this fact of
her life and it's retroactively made her
the first known lgbtqia plus person in
space
even now this is a little remarked on
aspect of her life while her Wikipedia
entry does talk about her relationships
it doesn't once use the word lesbian
even though that word appears in the
headlines of some of the cited sources
but there is simply no disputing Sally
Ride
not straight
it should come as little surprise
there's going to be a fair few artistic
Types on this list it wasn't just gonna
stop with Langston Hughes and da Vinci
so now we're going to talk about what
many consider to be the greatest
playwright if not the greatest writer in
the English language
that's right my friends we're talking
about good old Billy shakes William
Shakespeare is always an easy one to get
controversial about since you can't even
get all of Academia to agree that he
even wrote his own plays uh he totally
did by the way every single theory that
says otherwise is based on pure
speculation no concrete evidence and an
underlying refusal to accept to the very
notion that a commoner could have been
so talented which is why the alternate
theories are always about someone who is
of noble standing or another it's just
classism and elitism pure and simple the
guy wrote his own stuff but anyway
Shakespeare's sexuality is an
interesting one because it's an easily
verified fact that at the age of 18 he
married Anne Hathaway no not that one
and together they had three kids
however it's also easily verified that
he'd soon abandon his family in order to
move to London so for whatever reason
didn't seem like he had a happy home
life
of course that alone only means so much
I mean plenty of straight people have on
Happy marriages and it still seems very
likely that Shakespeare had an
attraction to women with some even
speculating about Affairs such as the
mysterious dark lady brought up in
multiple of his love sonnets and the
sonnets is where we find some very
interesting tidbits because out of the
154 sonnets
126 of them deal in some way with what
has come to be known as the fair youth
this includes possibly the most famous
sauna of all sonnet 18 the shall I
compare thee to a summers day one at
this point virtually no credible
academic argues against the fair youth
being male and different theories on who
it might have been are out there yet
some still try to avoid the topic of how
sincere and sexual the attraction
appears to be
but uh let's let the man speak for
himself and take an example
let's go with sonnet 20. a woman's face
with Nature's Own hand-painted hast thou
the master Mistress of my passion a
woman's gentle heart but not acquainted
with shifting change as is false woman's
fashion an eye more bright than theirs
less false in Rolling gilding the object
whereuponic gazeth a man in Hue all Hues
in his controlling which steals men's
eyes and women's Souls a mazeth and for
a woman would thou first created till
nature as she wrote the fella doting and
by addition me of thee defeated by
adding one thing to my purpose nothing
but since she pricked thee out for
women's pleasure mine be thy love and
thy loves use their treasure I mean
come on now and don't give me any of
that
about platonic loving ye olden days
stuff because frankly we have the man's
literal professions of love that he gave
for his characters in his place to say
and it's the same damn thing William
Shakespeare
not straight oh you think it's been
controversial so far this next one's
Really Gonna ruffle some feathers
Founding Father
Hamilton these days is best known as the
subject of a stage musical but before
that he fought in the Revolutionary War
for American Independence was the first
Secretary of the Treasury was married
with several children and may very well
have been getting it on with his friend
John Laurens on the side for a while
you think people have been touching
about some of the ones I brought up
before
oh boy do the status quo Warriors go off
on the suggestion that a founder of this
great nation might have been enjoying a
blow on the opan flu with his War buddy
now and then
[Music]
[Applause]
many others in this video I can't
definitively prove my position on this
and even though I'm going to offer you
some quotes from Hamilton's own letters
there's going to be a flurry of voices
about how this is all just the flowery
language of the time and that's possible
but
well
let's take a listen shall we cold in my
professions warm in my friendships I
wish my dear Lawrence it might be in my
power by action rather than words to
convince you that I love you I shall
only tell you that till you bid us a dew
I hardly knew the value you had taught
my heart to set upon you indeed my
friend it was not well done
you know the opinion I entertain of
mankind how much it is my desire to
preserve myself free from particular
attachment to keep my happiness
independent on the Caprice of others you
should not have taken advantage of my
sensibility to steal into my affections
without my consent
how much sexual or romantic intent you
want to read into that is ultimately up
to you but it does factually amount to
saying I love you man but you know how
much I hate people so I'm kind of pissed
that I like you so much
then there's this one I acknowledge but
one letter from you since you left us on
the 14th of July which just arrived in
time to appease a violent conflict
between my friendship and my pride
I have written you five or six letters
since you left Philadelphia and I should
have written you more had you made
proper return but like a jealous lover
when I thought you slided my caress my
affection was alarmed and my vanity
peaked
and yes flowery language of the time and
yes Hamilton only says that he is like a
jealous lover not that he actually is
one but at the same time he was more
than happy to compare himself to a lover
and his letters to caresses of all the
metaphors available even in the realm of
Flowery language that feels carefully
selected
I could keep going on this one this guy
really didn't do succinct letters and
this could be the entire rest of the
video so let's just bullet point a few
things upon his engagement he wrote to
Lawrence comparing his impending wedding
to his doom and practically begged
Lawrence to come and visit him not as a
new topic but as a direct continuation
of his dismantle wedding and all in the
same paragraph
is all of this definitive proof no and
admittedly this one is a little bit more
of a stretch than some of the others on
this list but given that I found even
discussion of the possibility of this
gets shouted down and drowned out
immediately I couldn't resist Alexander
Hamilton
possibly not straight
in either middle school or high school
English class you were probably
introduced to the Poetry of one Emily
Dickinson you know the because I could
not stop for death he kindly stopped for
me lady well despite not being regularly
acknowledging classrooms it's largely
agreed at this point that Dickinson had
a deep and sexually charged love towards
her sister-in-law Susan exactly how
reciprocal this relationship was or how
far it ever went physically is still
argued to some degree but it's not
really debated much these days that
Dickinson's pulled towards her
sister-in-law was
quite sexual in nature
instead it's a topic just avoided as
much as possible but it was pretty well
laid out in this excerpt from a letter
Emily wrote to Susan Susie will you
indeed come home next Saturday and be my
own again and kiss me I hope for you so
much and feel so eager for you that I
cannot wait feel that now I must have
you that the expectation once more to
see your face again makes me feel hot
and feverish and my heart beats so fast
my darling so near I seem to you that I
disdained this pen and wait for a warmer
language
that woman was thirsty
Emily Dickinson
not straight
we've done a lot of artsy fartsy stuff
so who's ready for some science Sir
Isaac Newton developed some of the
foundational principles of physics even
to this day his famous three laws of
motion and theory of gravity were huge
leaps forward in our understanding of
the natural world
it's also really unlikely that he was
straight now with Newton it's been
basically known forever that the guy
never married never had children had no
known Affairs and it's often argued he
may in fact have died of urgent some
have made the argument that in fact he
had sexual entanglements with men the
main basis for that being his apparent
revulsion at the suggestion that he have
relationships with women so just an
assumption that since he found a woman
icky he must get with men as far as the
evidence for that he didn't like women
well he once accused his friend John
Locke of having quote endeavored to
embroil me with women
it's been suggested that his friends
attempting to get him to have a
heterosexual relationship may have been
a contributing factor to his mental
breakdown in 1693 but a strong distaste
for the idea of being with a woman does
not automatically mean he had a desire
for men as seems to have been the
Assumption in the past rather
it seems far more likely that Newton
would fit rather comfortably under the
label of asexual which yes is part of
the queer Community Sir Isaac Newton
not straight
this next one I won't lie is one that
I'm genuinely kind of nervous to talk
about but here we go
Malcolm X was a vocal civil rights
advocate he was a Firebrand of a speaker
revered to this day for his passionate
speeches there's also a fair bit of
evidence that he had relationships with
men in his youth a number of historians
and biographers such as Manning Maribel
and Bruce Perry interviewed people who
knew Malcolm X at all ages of his life
and found numerous accounts of him
having private and likely sexual
encounters with men while in his early
twenties
this is something that his surviving
family has disputed and though some have
speculated that Malcolm X may have had
secret Affairs into his married life
there is virtually no actual evidence of
that having occurred so it becomes
understandable that his family would
push back because in the time they knew
him he may well have chosen to not share
this part of his history and it's also
worth noting that some accounts claimed
Malcolm X would sometimes be paid by the
often older men he was said to spend
time with
so it's also at least possible that
these weren't genuine feelings of
same-sex attraction so much as a
willingness to engage in the activity if
the price was right
that's part of why I was hesitant to
include Malcolm X on this list because I
have to acknowledge it's at least
possible that any same-sex sexual
activity he engaged in may have been
coerced by Financial circumstances if
nothing else
but at the same time
it's equally possible that he engaged in
some activities freely while taking pay
for others in the end I can't know the
exact circumstances and if I leave him
out of the conversation just because
it's not the most comfortable of
examples for me to talk about
well that kind of Erasure is what I'm
here to try and cover in the first place
Malcolm X
likely not straight while we already
talked about a Founding Father earlier
let's see if we can Sully the White
House proper a little bit shall we
I'm not with an actual president but the
next best thing
first lady Eleanor Roosevelt the wife of
four-time President Franklin D Roosevelt
is a revered figure beloved in her time
and after and while historians would
learn over time that both she and her
husband engaged in Affairs and uh
actually seem to be aware that the other
was doing that meaning we may all this
time have been failing to recognize the
first polyamorous president but that's a
whole other conversation the twist in
all this is that Eleanor's Affairs were
with women it actually appears to have
been a bit of an Open Secret among the
White House staff that Eleanor Roosevelt
was a lesbian and whether she was ever
sexually attracted to FDR or not she
certainly showed plenty of affection for
the women in her life
here's an excerpt from a letter she sent
to journalists Lorena Hickok whom she'd
given the affectionate nickname of hick
heck darling all day I've thought of you
and another birthday and I will be with
you
and yet tonight you sounded so far away
and so formal
oh I want to put my arms around you I
ache to hold you close
your ring is a great comfort to me I
look at it and I think she does love me
or I wouldn't be wearing it uh that ring
she's referencing by the way uh was worn
by Eleanor at FDR's Inauguration in
1933.
she wrote to Hickok daily sometimes up
to 15 pages per letter so if you want to
find more of this there's plenty of it
but uh here's another lovely bit
funny everything I do my thoughts fly to
you
never are you out of my heart I wish I
could lie down beside you tonight
and take you in my arms now while
Roosevelt's affection is pretty
undeniable whether or not that love was
ever consummated is less certain but
whether or not she ever did get to lie
down beside the woman she loved and take
her in her arms the fact remains
Eleanor Roosevelt
not straight
why don't we round things out with
another artist possibly Mexico's most
famous artists Magdalena Carmen Frida
Kahlo icaldoron
I usually refer to as just Frida Kahlo
was renowned for her portraits
particularly her self-portraits and was
married to fellow painter Diego Rivera
their marriage was
turbulent including a divorce and a
Reconciliation callous bisexuality isn't
really a point of dispute having lived
in the early 20th century not nearly as
much of her life has become fogged by
time as some of the others that we've
discussed and she seemed to do little to
hide her interest in women so instead we
see an attempt to minimize the
importance or relevance of her being
bisexual most historical accounts will
gloss over it if not ignore it entirely
and given her marriage fraught though it
was was to a man it's become common for
an argument to be made that her
relations with men were more meaningful
to her than those with women
that's of course pretty speculative as
it's just as possible that they were
equally important but given the
acceptance of heterosexual relationships
that's what she engaged in more
frequently and more openly but even if
it's true and if her dalliances with
women were truly less deep or meaningful
that wouldn't make her any less bisexual
Frida Kahlo not straight
there we go trust me I've barely
scratched the surface of this there's a
ton more I could have included Walt
Whitman Angela Davis Virginia Woolf but
I I had to stop somewhere
I hope you had fun with this I know I
did
oh well writing and recording it was fun
moderating the comments probably won't
be but we'll see I do want to give my
thanks to all the wonderful creators who
lent their voices to this project you'll
find them listed in the description as
well as links to either YouTube channels
or other social media accounts they
might have
what did you think about some of these
hooks were any of these news to you were
you thinking to yourself as I went
through these yeah no I knew that
already or did I surprise you
whatever the case may be drop something
down in the comments let's talk about it
offer your own instances and examples of
similar situations
if you enjoyed this video want to
support what I do patreon is the best
way to do that that is what enables me
to do this as my living but uh the light
share subscribe are also helpful
ultimately though especially during
Pride what I want you to remember
is that you are beautiful
you are valid
and you are loved
you are the council I am just running
the meetings and until next time this
council is adjourned
[Music]
massive thanks to my patreon supporters
and in particular I want to thank Robin
Moore Zubin look full up to rock the
thing that goes doink in the anime Ruth
Oliver B solitary pictures
Ulrich Bogdan Melinda Walters Jen Leo
the Boyd Auntie Kate 808 Becky Sparks
for Nabi likes the poodle Robin Powell
Tracy scrabot angry Casper Adam RDL
Taylor David Hall Shayla gourlay and
Rosalind Bennett thanks for your support
you can get your name in the credits too
if you feel like hearing me possibly
struggle with it for several times
before getting it right
[Music]
foreign